en ce qui concerne le conflit proprement
dit une nouvelle négociation cet après
midi avec le ministre des affaires
sociales monsieur barreau n'a pas abouti
les cheminots ont tout de même obtenu de
conserver leur régime spécial de
retraite demain force ouvrière la cgt
appelle à une nouvelle journée de grèves
contre la réforme de la sécurité sociale
le trafic ferroviaire risque d'être pour
la cinquième journée consécutive
très fortement perturbé pascal golomer
laurent bertrand
la grève a été reconduite séance
d'information cet après midi au fond
d'un hangar une petite poignée de
grévistes
lester dentaires comme on les appelle
ils travaillent en principe au guichet
de la gare de l'est
ils sont désormais tout aussi déterminé
que leurs collègues roulant à poursuivre
le mouvement
quand le président bergougnoux qu'on
voit que les organisations syndicales on
pouvait être pensez peut-être qu'il
avait d'autres propositions à faire sur
le contrat de plan il n'en est rien donc
aujourd'hui nous n'avons aucune raison
et les cheminots d'ailleurs le montre
massivement encore aujourd'hui pour
arrêter le mouvement
aucune avancée aujourd'hui du côté de la
direction de la sncf
surprise en revanche en début d'après
midi jacques barrot invite tous les
syndicats à son ministère pour évoquer
évidemment le fameux régime des
retraites
départ à 55 ans et durée de cotisation
moindre que dans le privé un régime que
le gouvernement veut réformer mais
auquel s'accrochent les cheminots ce
soir le ministre l'a promis
rien n'est décidé objecté consolidation
à moyen et long terme de nos régimes
spéciaux de retraite méthode
une commission composée de personnalités
indépendantes et compétentes assurances
il y aura une concertation approfondie
pour les syndicats près de quoi être
rassuré cernant le statut notamment le
régime de retraite gouvernement n'a pas
l'intention manifestement il a donné des
signes d'apaisement aux cheminots rien 9
confirmation d'une mobilisation
nécessaire pour continuer d'essayer de
faire reculer le gouvernement sur cet
aspect particulier comme sur la question
du contrat plan et ils se retrouveront
tous demain sous une seule banderole
dans la manifestation contre le plan ses
clés du gouvernement